[Musique]
c'est un rapport assez édifiant qu'à
publier l'observatoire des
multinationales alors que nous sommes en
pleine crise qu vide et que la politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte de l'état n'est
pas encore terminée 24 pages qu'on ne va
pas pouvoir vous détailler en une minute
trente
du coup on va juste vous sortir quelques
chiffres assez pertinents alors que 100
% des entreprises du cac 40 total sanofi
lvmh et autres auraient touché des aides
de l'état que ce soit sous forme
d'exonérations de charges chômage
partiel ou à travers les fameux pge
elles vont reverser cette année 51
milliards d'euros de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
près de 20 % de plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
la france étant le pays d'europe ayant
le plus cdc entreprises en 2020 avec
d'ailleurs assez peu de condition ça
fait forcément tâche
d'ailleurs autre chiffre 80% des
entreprises ayant versé de l'argent à
leurs actionnaires cette année ou
l'année dernière où le recours au
chômage partiel
parallèlement à ça le cac40 aurait
également licencié près de soixante deux
mille cinq cents personnes dans le monde
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
dont trente mille en france
mais alors qui sont ces fameux
actionnaires qui touchent des dividendes
iq sont nombreux mais en top position de
ceux ayant reçu le plus avec 1,7
milliard d'euros
on trouve par exemple le fonds
d'investissement blackrock ayant investi
dans la quasi totalité des grandes
entreprises tricolores en deuxième
position
devinez quoi bah c'est l'état un peu
plus de 1,6 milliard ou comprend donc un
peu mieux pourquoi à freiner les
dividendes des grandes entreprises
françaises n'étaient pas forcément une
priorité